طب احنا اليوم عندنا قصه جميله جدا
انا كنت اتمنى انه في اختراع ينقلكم
الرائحه عبر الكاميرا عشان تسمون الروائح
الجميله خاصه الان عندنا في السعوديه ثوره
عطور صراحه كثير من البراندات السعوديه
بدات تتعلق اكثر فاكثر ايضا اليوم نتحدث
مع الاستاذ مشاري العنزان مشاري واحد
الشباب السعوديين اللي ابتكروا براند خاص
فيه
ونال احد العطور الخاصه في همم من التوب 5
في العالم جائزه عالميه في سنه 20 22 همم
طبعا كل كل فصل عطر ولكل حاله عطر ولكل
مزاج عطر ايضا فنتكلم اليوم مع مشاري همم
صباح الخير مشاري
خلينا نتكلم اول شيء هل فعلا في عطور
شتويه وعطور صيفيه ولا العطر الفصول طبيعي
همم لكل فصل رائحته يعني في مثل همم
اا عطر العود ما يناسب لفصل الصيف اللي هو
هذا العطر لكن يكون من العطور المرغوبه في
فصل الشتاء ايش المكونات اللي تنفع الفصل
الشتاء يعني انا مثلا ابغى عطر شتوي يليق
بالاجواء يليق بالفصل ايش المكونات اللي
بتكون لازم موجوده
الان هذا العطر الان اول باخه هي الانطباع
الاول
حق العطر هل هو يوسفي بودر فانيليا
العطر
بعد دقائق يبدا العطر يعطيك
هي المكونات
هي متغيره
العطر اشوف المكونات اشوف الريحه التي
تطلع معي بعدها اخذ همم منه عينه وارسلها
للمصانع لاكبر المصانع في العالم اقول لهم
هذا العطر نبغاه يكون همم بنفس هذه
المكونات يصدرنا عطر خاص في العلاماتنا
التجاريه
فانا ابغاك عبد الرحمن تبدا تجرب المنتجه
هذه
ههه طبعا انا بالنسبه لي هذا هو زيت بس
انا سويت منه بالكحول لانه ما عندي كحول
الان بخليك تجربه تنقل الصوره بكل الوضوء
الله
هذا العطر لسه
جدا جدا
[موسيقى]
والله اسم حلو اسميه عاجز على الكلام
بس انا احب نادين وسهام انا احب العطور
انا شخصيا العطر اللي ريحته تكون فيها
غرابه لكن نفس الوقت
مختلفه يعني انا ما احب العطر التقليدي في
روائح تقليديه تشمها كثير وفي عطور لا لما
تشمه تحس انه يعني مختلف ما تشمها كثير
هذا ثلاث سنوات
اي شيء
ههه
ما ابغى اي شيء
من ضمن النوتات اللي ناقصه علامه التجاريه
ابدا ابحث عن افضل
مكونات من التوب التوبه ونشوف همم
تركب مع هذه بعدين خاطب الشركات نبغى نبغى
المكون يكون بالاول والثاني وكذا وكذا
وكذا شكرا جزيلا الله يسعد صباحك بالخير
شكرا
انا شكلي حنان هنا خلاص مش هاطلع من
المكان
الهديه
ان شاء الله الله يسعدك ويطول عمرك يسعد
صباحكم شكرا جزيلا لكم من رياض بمراسل
صباح العربيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي شكرا عبد
الرحمن